yeah what about matrix though the matrix
i mean do you really feel that strongly
about the matrix honestly as a kid yeah
i did
as a kid yeah i feel like it's one of
those things where i i just care about
it it's like referential
like it's so famous and so referenced
yeah but now i don't really give a [ __ ]
about the matrix yeah i don't really
give a [ __ ]
i don't really give a revolutionary when
it came out yeah it was like whoa
you can do that i also bias like that
[ __ ] scene where they put the
thing inside of it the stomach gave me
nightmares i mean i've already talked
about that
yeah that [ __ ] gave me nightmares i
will say
um i don't think the matrix has aged
very well oh no definitely
i've definitely especially the first one
i've definitely rewatched it and i'm
just like oh
god i thought this was really cool i
thought this was like the coolest thing
when it came out because that's that's
why
it's kind of [ __ ] it's kind of [ __ ] it
definitely has an age wall no it
definitely has no age
but that's because there's been since
the matrix there's been a million matrix
yeah
i just shot better but i mean like i
feel like part of the big reason i got
into anime was
because of the matrix as well because
i'm just like i see this and then
this was like my anime taste for a long
time because i thought this was cool as
[ __ ] and i wanted to find more things
like this
iconic as [ __ ] yeah it's iconic as [ __ ]
and i remember i think the first time i
saw this when did this come out in
97 i think okay i think i was like nine
or ten when i first saw it it's way too
young to be seeing this
yeah yeah yeah um but i remember
thinking this was like the coolest thing
which it was it was for the time right
before the time showing your age there
when he like pulls the red and blue
pillow
i was like yeah which one is he gonna be
but by my my age when i
was old enough to be able to appreciate
it it kind of fallen out oh definitely
because
it was like what like 16 so yeah at that
time right they'd already been a million
coins of matrix
by the time it came up for you like you
people were dressed like people in the
matrix are like neck beards with
holding a katana with like a fedora
right this is like
you think you if the matrix was made
nowadays it's just like the person who's
just learned the way of the blade
yeah i didn't really watch many like
nerd movies though growing up like i
never what defines a nerd
yeah what defines the nerd movie star
wars i've still yet to watch the
original star wars trilogy really
i just lord of the rings or anything
like that i love lord of the rings okay
i mean that's probably the nerdiest
i haven't watched lord of the rings the
[ __ ] you haven't watched a lot of the
rings wait what's weird
you haven't much stall no you're a
[ __ ] you're both [ __ ] weird to me
you haven't watched star wars you
haven't watched it i feel like you have
to watch lord of the rings
i feel like you have to watch star wars
in that sense you don't i don't you
don't have to
okay you don't have to watch one two and
three just at least four five six
yeah i've only watched one two and three
that i don't count that as watching star
wars i've i've not watched the original
trilogy you have to watch the original
trailer i just don't give a [ __ ] if you
sat
through 12 hours of lord of the rings
you can sit through three star wars i
love
i used to watch like the director's cut
of lord of the rings
yeah but we used to go to france every
holiday yeah yeah and uh
it was a 12-hour journey and i was like
oh like longer than 12 so i was like
great i'll watch
the lord of the rings director cuts back
to back in one city oh my god
i like lord of the rings but that's too
much lord of the rings the reason i
haven't watched lord of the rings is
okay i have watched the first movie
fell asleep thought it was boring never
came back really
how old were you when did it come out
a lot of the the first one fellowship of
the ring came out in like
mid-2000s right did it i think it was
yeah wait like 2003 or something yeah
so i remember my cousin watching it um
and he was like
oh one holy [ __ ] it's a 20 year old
movie so i think i was about like
13 14 when i attempted to watch it and i
don't know like
how that's like the prime time though i
feel
i this is gonna sound weird from like
coming from the isekai guy
i just i just don't find fantasy or that
interesting what the [ __ ] that's
all you [ __ ] talk about that's all
you talk about okay okay okay okay
watch it now you like fantasy
go back and watch it now yeah anime
fantasy
yeah i [ __ ] slept i [ __ ] [ __ ] with
that real life fantasy get the [ __ ] out
of my face oh my god what a weeb
go watch it actually give it a shot if
it doesn't have a hot anime titties in
an inside world i don't want it
basically i appreciate it is the main
character overpowered no frodo's like
afraid i can't do [ __ ] he just is so
good that's why it's good because
he fights through all of these like
insanely impossible to survive
situations
with the power of friendship bro but
every single movie has
just amazing scenes in it dude sam best
waifu i'm just saying right now
he's best waifu dude he supports frodo
till from start to finish what's your
favorite lord of the rings movie joey
probably the third one see that's what i
mean you can say any single any one of
those movies is the best movie
and i i i'm like that's totally fair
like every single movie is great all
three movies are fantastic ah dude yeah
so good yeah maybe we should watch it
together it's long though it's it's long
yeah
we don't have to watch the director's
cut and [ __ ] like we can we can watch
the normal ones which is still like 10
hours but
still the director's cut can only really
be appreciated after you've loved the
first card yeah because
you want the bonus stuff yeah exactly
you need to make sure you love it first
okay i'm speaking you began to watch
lord of the rings i'm sitting down
no no no no no no i don't think you do i
don't feel like soldiers aren't
necessary honestly honestly i'm i'm
i'm uh okay well i've pissed off lord of
the rings fans
let me piss off star wars say it all
right say
i know the plot to the uh the original
trilogy yeah
like darth vader i just think darth
vader looks [ __ ] boring
i've played the lego games so i know the
story
so i basically know star wars guys i
know the story and i just think that
like darth maul
[ __ ] badass okay to be fair general
grievous uh
only the coolest [ __ ] yeah general
grievous is the
coolest [ __ ] uh star wars character i
guess he is to be fair to be fair
[Music]
i'm just going to say i think episode
one is actually really [ __ ] good i
think it's well obviously because i
prefer the previous
small fight and the pod racing is like
the two greatest scenes in star wars
honestly like
because the reason i prefer the prequels
to defend myself is okay
number one i really don't give a [ __ ]
about star wars
it's it's fair it's just not something
i'm interested in i'm not passionate
about star wars either yeah yeah
the lego games are just banging that was
great
sure and it's just like i remember
watching i've actually seen the
original trilogy a lot of times because
someone's always got it on in the
background
someone's always watching at some
[ __ ] family um family gathering or
something was
like playing at christmas i don't know
why but someone's always watching this
i've seen it so many [ __ ] times and i
i kind of find it like just boring i
don't
it's just a very standard movie
with like it's it's it's just uh
what's original about star wars nowadays
well nowadays it's not because again
like very much like matrix it's just
being copied to [ __ ] it's kind of just
like the matrix to me where it's just it
to me it's just boring now it's just a
very normal standard movie and she's
like yeah
luke goes on the hero's journey and
darth vader is the villain and yada yada
yeah that's why that wasn't really
interesting that's why i never like
cared to watch episodes seven eight and
nine because in my mind i'm just like
it's not really like a fantasy to like
but like people like hate the last two
movies yeah i think so yeah
episode seven was the only one where
people were like it was pretty good yeah
but like to me there are so many like
scenes in the in the prequels that just
stand out to me
like that [ __ ] jewel with darth maul
and like okay [ __ ]
gin and everyone holy [ __ ] that is
iconic
to this day still is the best spicy
styles and it has the best theme oh my
god the ball theme dude yeah yeah
that's what was terrifying as well darth
maul was [ __ ] tough
[ __ ] darth vader yeah like like what's
what's what's scary about someone having
asthma
i have asthma does that make me [ __ ]
scary no also
in the prequels we didn't get to see
anakin kill the kids yeah i like that
part
i like are you kidding me like like the
first time you see like
um count dooku fight yoda holy [ __ ] man
that was that
church for me to me that was like by far
the one
the star wars the only thing that i mean
the only thing that works
the original three episodes is that
jonah is literally in all of them
yoda is literally a puppet people love
that though yeah i know but
i said i don't get that i prefer when
he's like you know has a motion in his
face yeah yeah no i i
i liked him when he was [ __ ] sharp
yeah when he was like flipping in the
air
when he brings out the lightsaber he
starts like doing [ __ ] like
gymnastics and all this [ __ ]
i love samuel jackson bro yeah samuel
jackson
like samuel jackson is the only thing
that made the clone wars bearable yeah
yeah yeah yeah when he pulls out the
purple lights and i was like my man
let's go
because like the coolest the only thing
i actually gave a [ __ ] about star wars
was the jedis
and what's not in the [ __ ] like
what's hardly in
the original trilogy and like the
sequels it's the jedis
that's what i wanted i want to see cool
jedi's fights i want to see cool
lightsaber fights
also all the best memes come from the
prequels yeah
yeah it did get mean to [ __ ] yeah
definitely so yeah i i'm i'm i'm
sticking by my gun i prefer
the star wars prequels come at me star
wars i won't have any dislikes this
clips
i just yeah star wars is kind of boring
you know i mean it's kind of weird
i'm not gonna sit here and pretend like
it's the greatest fantasy story ever but
i mean you know
it's decent i mean that's the biggest
thing i'm more passionate about not
caring about star wars and like lord of
the rings i've seen
some of like the action scenes there i'm
like i could probably get into it
there's just the battles
bro the battles are [ __ ] happening
helms deep bro got me acting up so good
battles are so good all the rings yeah
we still haven't had battles as good as
lord of the rings
it's been like 20 years and no nothing
has come close dude give me another hour
and a half long fight scene man
it's insane bro that guy literally
pitched that and they were like all
right
let's do it so you want the fight scenes
to be howling
yeah and they [ __ ] did it but they
did it it's an hour and a half
like battle scene okay and it just
doesn't that doesn't cut away
amazing it's literally an hour and a
half fine amazing all right i guess
you've sold me i guess i guess they
still
build character and story yeah in the in
a battle without like [ __ ] disbelief
of
what's going on is everything it's like
literally they're like in the middle of
[ __ ] they're literally monologuing as
they're fighting
because i i actually remember why i
stopped watching lord of the rings
because i was actually watching it with
my cousin and
so they go on this journey and i kept
asking are they there yet
she got so [ __ ] pissed off with me
because i'm just like
it's like because i was just like
they're there yeah when are they going
to get there we're going to get there
like are they close to coming there and
they're like he's like god shut the [ __ ]
up
you also can't watch lord of the rings
with someone who is a geo fan
no because if they you need someone to
shut the [ __ ] up when you're watching
god oh my god
that's my paper okay please people who
love lord of the rings unfortunately
will tell you everything about lord of
the rings
throughout every single moment yeah okay
yeah please don't be
that guy who just quotes the movie as it
happens
i i literally can't stand that it is my
least favorite thing and like what's
even worse
is like not even when they're quoting it
out out loud when they think they're
being conspicuous about it and they just
like like start mouthing to themselves
no the one i hate more is when they
whisper to themselves yeah right before
it happens yeah
yeah yeah when they're like i get it
you've seen this movie seventeen
thousand times shut the [ __ ] up
when people like oh this part's good
it's like well i'll i'll decide that
don't tell me the card's good i'm
about to [ __ ] watch it i'll decide if
this part is good yeah don't be that guy
please
yeah all that part i mean i mean i i've
like i
you know you always have that part where
you show someone a movie you really like
but i try to be as subtle about it as i
can because like
in my mind i'm like this good this good
part's coming up and like try to like
see on the corner of my eye if they're
watching it like if if if
if i was invisible i'd be like full on l
mode you know like that scene from
definitely just like
don't look at me like that that's that's
the other pet peeve i have when i'm
showing
a movie to a friend or whoever and and
in my head i'm like oh this next scene
they're going to love and i look over
and they're just out on their
oh god don't be that guy yeah don't be
like etiquette come on movie etiquette
but anyway that's my three by three
these are not my favorite films or some
of these i
[ __ ] with um still some of these are
just there because
well i mean they're a child of movies
they're my childhood movies that's what
3x3 is all about yeah
well yeah i definitely need to watch
kung fu hustle and confessions yeah